Hello, everybody. This is Dr. Kamikaze and we are live on a holistic health
hour. So let me get the chat connected so we're ready to go. I apologize today. I
have a really bad cold and summer colds are not fun to have. But we have some
questions we want to get to. So remember reminder always to go to holistichealthhour.com.
That's where you can find all our all the holistic health hours very nicely organized
for you to find different topics. So if you're looking for a specific question answered
but you're not able to you know get it answered on our live show you can always go there we may
have answered it. Also I may have answered your question multiple times on a blog post.
So go to ConnersClinic.com and look at our blog post. Remember I see I went at ERS clinic. Oh it's
right there down in there. Left hand corner your screen. So look at our blogs unless to have
1200 blog posts. All sorts of different topics. So you can't find your topic.
That's what this is for. So chat in your questions on the holistichealthhour.com. You could also
ask questions and that's what we're going to start with the questions that were asked on that.
Okay first question that came in on the holistichealthhour.com question site.
I have some kind of infection in my body that I cannot get rid of. I can't fix the
structural wall of my chest back. Believe it originated in the stomach possibly H. Pylora.
It's antibiotic resistant affects my brain. I cite muscles all my joints. I'm unable to get
IV antibiotic therapy. So I don't know where the question is of that except you know maybe what
to this possibly be. So when you have an antibiotic resistant infection it certainly could be a
bacteria that you're just not getting the right antibiotics. So getting whatever affected area
cultured contested for what is good to be the best antibiotic if it is a bacteria is the right thing
to do if you have a chronic infection. The other thing possibility is that it's not a bacteria. So if
it's not a bacteria that antibiotics aren't going to help at all. So if you're trying to you know take
care of some chronic viral infection with an antibiotic it's not going to work. Chronic infections
are real. You can't have bacteria, viruses, parasites, different fungi that are resistant to
your immune system's ability to kill them for all sorts of different reasons. On our chronic
Lyme course I go into details on the different reasons that that happens. These different organisms
have the ability to hide within your normal microbiota. They have the ability to create walls around them
so that your immune system can't kill it and worse they have the ability sometimes to go
intracellular. So if they go inside of a cell then your immune system isn't going to kill something
your immune system doesn't go inside the cell. So if they're hiding within cells and they're
replicating and they're going outside of cells and making you sick and that operation continues yeah
you could have what's called a chronic infection. So it could be bacterial, it could be viral. There's
tests that you could do to find out there is if you know what's a pathogen running a pathogen antibody
which is a CyRex array 12 I think it is can be helpful to know what you're dealing with.
I will say that there's people that think that they may have a chronic pathogen but really they just
have a chronic autoimmune disease that has yet to be diagnosed. So getting proper workup is really
important. Running antibody tests for self tissue is important to just rule things out because it
may not you may not have the presence of a pathogen anymore. You're just getting these chronic symptoms
because of an autoimmune issue especially when you talk about the things that you mentioned here
affects my brain, my eyesight muscles and all my joints. You start thinking of possibly a systemic
autoimmune disease or an autoimmune disease that's affecting your brain. So neural tissue. So if you
have an autoimmune disease that's affecting neural tissue you have the inflammation that's chronic
in your brain and it can affect basically anywhere in your body then. So if you get these weird symptoms
that move around that's very common. So those are the kind of things that I would do instead of trying
to get IV antibiotics. I wouldn't figure out what is actually causing my problem. I've seen people
that were convinced that they had chronic Lyme and that the infection was still present
and they went on IV antibiotics and it just destroyed their gut and made them much worse and didn't
leave them in a better state. When in fact their issues worked they did have chronic Lyme but their
issues worked that they had a current infectious organism. They didn't have the presence of a current
infectious organism. They had the effects of what that organism did which would left their body in a
state where they had created antibodies against self tissue so they had an autoimmune disease
never diagnosed and that was what was giving them their majority of their symptoms.
So the going on the IV antibiotics just made their problems or so they simply didn't want that.
So getting a proper workout would be the right thing in a order or whatever if you do want to work with us
you know if you want to work with somebody local and find a local functional medicine doctor if you
want to work with us you can certainly do so go on coderscleric.com again and you can schedule now
you'd schedule if you've ever had an appointment with me for you'd schedule with what's called a case
review. So case review is your initial review with us and then we'll be with me on the phone and we'll
talk about your case and I'll give you some insight hopefully and points are the right to actually
least based upon my opinion so that may be something that everybody's looking for. The next question
is quite long and I do it to the comment you know I want to help everybody but when you're something's
just warrant you know a workout so this person is currently taking war for him for two blood clotting
issues factor five lane in May 3rd or syndrome I would like to switch to a natural supplement if possible
I haven't appointment with my doctor coming up to discuss this with her I've read a little a bit about
lumbrosine and I'm wondering if that would be an alternative to war for him by as it would be no
or if you have other suggestions that are most potent natural substitute for blood there would be
garlic but I would be careful because if you have an auto immune disease and you're taking garlic
also garlics also going to be an immune stimulant that's going to make things worse so you got to weigh
those all out I don't think that your doctor would be in game 4 you switching off war for him for
garlic or something like that so you know I can't give you any recommendations based upon medications
whether you should or should not take that I'm pretty sure your doctor's probably not going to be
in the same game there I was given a blood there this person goes in to give me some more details of
their history and stuff so remember this that's my comment about your questions we got to keep your
questions to very general things if you're going to get very specific with your questions of your
health history really need to do a case review if you want my opinions about that so I have to keep
this general understand this is going live to a lot of people and there's no way that I can get
real specific with specific case issues without getting a full history and a workup and things like
that I don't everybody listening understands that so set up a case review if you want to go a little bit
deeper next question I'm dealing with cobalt toxicity from bilateral hip implants 19 years ago
while in the process of hip revisions to remove the cobalt you recommend anything to help with heavy
metal detox systemically I think they meant the thing is if you're if you have the implants in your
body right now you can't do heavy metal detox so let's let's rephrase that answer if you have
metal implants in your body that you're having issues with so it is leaching that metal into your
body so therefore you're having issues with it and you use a heavy key later so typically in order to
pull metal out of heavy metals out of your tissues you would use a key later now understand
I have labeled that phase of detoxification as phase zero so I don't think you have any business
doing that for a couple of reasons number one if you still have the implants you should not be doing
any heavy key layers that's like if you have mercury fillings and you're going to do heavy
keylation all you're going to be doing is pulling that possibly out of your teeth into your body
it's just this is foolishness so you've got to not use heavy key layers if you have a piece of
metal in your body and you're trying to and you're having a reaction to it you have to get the
metal removed and then you key late excess metal that is systemic in your body through key layers but
you don't do keylation therapy oral or IV keylation therapy and tell you support of the other
six phases of detoxification I could find more information on our website on the seven phases of
detoxification I've written a little short booklet on that I have videos on that and I have a complete
course on the seven phases of detoxification quite quickly you have to support everything else
because if you're going to keylate it out of the tissue you're pulling it out of the tissue
where's it going it's going to the bloodstream and where's it going from there it's not going to
the toilet it's going through your liver so that your liver has to take it through phase one two and
three in your liver get it placed into the bile it travels from the bile down the bile ducts
stored in the gallbladder and then it's transported into the small intestine then it's transported
through 30 feet of intestines and hopefully into the toilet now those all consist of what I call
phase one two three four five six and you don't have any business of keylating things out into the blood
unless you support in all those other phases of detoxification first or most likely you're just
going to make yourself sicker so number one if you still have the implants to answer this person's
question you should not do any keylation once you get the implants removed and replaced with
something safer then you could do keylation but only after you've addressed those other six
phases of detoxification if you're correct you can do this concurrently but you've got to deal with
those other six phases of detoxification if you're really interested in our courses are I think the
detox courses 49 dollars or something like that go on that it's be a good 49 dollars spent to
understand those phases to support those things it doesn't have to be difficult it doesn't have to be
confusing but I tried to that's why I put the course together to help you understand but I just
seen over 30 years of doing this kind of stuff as seeing people get sick doing a key later while I'm
doing this detoxification program the keylate heavy metals in my doctor put me on you know EDTA
to pull out heavy metals and I just got super super sick that's because your liver was congested
so all you do is pull them out of with the EDTA which actually works you pull it out of the
tissues put it into the blood it had no room to get through the liver because the liver was already
congested so it just got deposited elsewhere it circulated around cross maybe worse cross the
blood barrier that's also damaged and you made yourself much worse you don't want to do that so
follow the seven phases of detoxification booklet or course and that will be the way to go but
in short you do not do keylation therapy at all if you have the metal still in your body so that's
just you just can't do that so you can support all the other six phases of detoxification that can
really help a lot but you can't any keylation therapy excuse me while you got the metal in your
body okay next question how to prepare for pregnancy okay that's a that's a that's a
that's a broad question because I don't know are you already pregnant if there's if you're already
pregnant then you you know there you just want to make sure you're getting your proper nutrition if
you're not pregnant if you're having difficulty getting pregnant or holding the pregnancy that's a
whole other picture that you want to look at getting a Dutch test done looking at your hormones
would be the right thing to do quite often estrogen dominance a progesterone deficiency
but we'd want to look at your at the picture there if you're just trying to say hey I'm ready to
start having babies and I want to be as healthy as possible well that's the same thing as if you're
trying to be as healthy as possible for anything so you know getting some lab work done seen what's
going on seen what I need to do to help balance my gut help you know to prevent if I could go into
the pregnancy as healthy as possible then I'm going to have less problems so um that's that's the
whole key so try to stay do everything you can to be as healthy as possible and and the thing is
is to get to get a good workout you know so get a good blood work up see where you're at would be
the thing that I would recommend question on the chat member you can chat in your questions wondering
are your thoughts about taking seamos gel okay so um I'm not a big fan of seamos for multiple reasons
I don't know um so remember with supplements there's a lot of like new things that come on the market
and and sometimes the producer of that new thing isn't really looking out for people's best interest
it's just hey if we can push this new thing we can make money um yeah well that's the downside of
capitalism is that lots of times there's this people try to make money on you and without you know
really a concern for whether it's good for you and this and I think I have some videos on different
supplement schemes to look for um and to know whether the supplement you're taking is a good
supplement or it's not your wasting your money or you could be even hurting yourself so and I
even had people come to me that are taking a supplement that was recommended by their carapter
naturopath or functional medicine doctor that's like it's just garbage why why would they recommend
this this is like mineral that is um uh in an elemental mineral I mean okay I'll give you an example
of since it doesn't have to do with seamos but like like um this is a really big in the supplement
marker right now is these liquid minerals so liquid elemental minerals are not good products
they're out there that's how we're supposed to get our minerals we get our minerals through good
grass fed meat or through vegetables so we eat our vegetables uh let's say vegetables take an
elemental mineral and then it's reformatted by the plant and double bonded to the amino acid and then
we eat that vegetable that's a mineral that's double bonded to the amino acid that's how we eat
are that's how we get are supposed to get our minerals and then that is easy to digest easy to absorb
and easy to go into a cell and function through the uh that supposed to that minerals supposed to
function within the cell elemental minerals are difficult to digest they're hard on our system
they can be very hard on our gut lining um they're not utilized very well um and they're not
absorbed very well it's just really a poor source of supplement but it's really pushed
hard because some supplement company came out with this new fancy product it's easy to take it's liquid
it's uh it's just not good for you it's just wrong um so seamos fits into the category seamos has some
other issues with it too i think i wrote a blog post about that but i can't remember um if not i can
look some of the more of that stuff up next question i use one graham packet of safe garden fed
vendors all daily for my cancer protocol when i tried taking two packets daily i was having chronic
diarrhea so i went back to one packet a day and started the sun fiber supplement so sun fiber is
a modified guar gum that is a great one of the best forms of fiber out there i finally became regular
for the first for the last month so i introduced the second packet of fed vendors all daily and after
a couple days the diarrhea started to give should i avoid doing it twice a day all together uh yes yes
i would so fed vendors all for those who don't know is a dewormer and the dosage that this person
is taking is a dog dosage um for a ten pound dog uh so what does that affect as i have on a human
it's a very low dose uh dewormer um and it shouldn't have very much affect as far as anti-parameter
parasitic in dewormer but some people can have sensitivity to it some people just have a sensitive
gut no typically when a person asked me if with this person was a patient they're asking me that question
i would be concerned about the health of their gut so i would say really we should run a syrex array
two because we really need to see if there's you know uh paracelular permeability transcellular
permeability or if you have antibodies to lipopolysaccharides because you shouldn't react to two
packets of this now i'd if we asked this question obviously if this person's very small or this person
has other health issues uh sounds like they're taking it for cancer so um but i would say you know
anytime you take anything um supplementally and you have a reaction to it you should stop taking it
so um you you know just because maybe your sister can take it you might have a sensitivity to it
you might need to deal with other things in your gut or something like that maybe you have it's not
a sensitivity but you have other gut permeability issues and it's just too much irritation maybe
there's some of the things you need to do there's just a lot of babies there so even good supplements
like okay curcumin curcumin is the active form of turmeric well that's great because it's an
anti-inflammatory it's a cancer killer it's a great supplement but it is a food and you can develop
antibodies against curcumin i've done you know different antibody tests on people and they have
antibodies for turmeric well they can't take curcumin so it's you know there's you know everybody's
a different human being so that's where when you look at advice that's on the internet or even
given by good doctors that are saying that everybody should do this or everybody should do that
maybe they just meet it in general but um i will say that everybody is different so you may be
different than your twin sister and you can't do the same thing so getting some proper testing done
is the right thing to do and in general if you have a reaction to something just stop it for a period of
time um and do some investigation maybe it wasn't that supplement at all maybe it was something else
that you ate that day that you had the reaction obviously this question it's quite obvious that it is
the fitment is all this person tested it they got their cut back in order or they tested it and
took it again and it happened again so pretty easy to see that but some things aren't as easy to see
and things could get blamed one of the things i make a mistake being a functional doctor
and i don't prescribe one of the things i'll just be honest that i'm creating a mistake off it is
forgetting that a lot of members of ours are also taking concurrently taking prescription medication
and they may say well i had this reaction the other day to this thing you know i got this in this
in this reaction i'm like oh well go to this let's change let's change your supplement protocol let's
do this let's do that let's check this and i forget what i'm gonna say so you're on this this this this this
drug uh let's look up side effects oh three of the four drugs you have have that as a side effect uh
maybe it's that um you know you just gotta investigate all those things and be wise sometimes just
involves you putting on your Sherlock Holmes hat and you just kind of figure these things out
but certainly finding a local doctor that could do testing could be a wise thing to do if you
want to work with us again you just schedule a case review with us um and uh get out our courses
i mean go to codersclinic.com i think this scrolling at the bottom of the screen is talking about
um our courses are um $50 for our autoimmune course and from there you can run labs and you
can set schedule you can schedule visits with us on such it's really a good buy if you really want
to take responsibility for your health and you okay uh and a couple other questions i wanted to
get to here person asked this question a few weeks ago and i didn't i don't think i got to it
what do i do if i get a tick bite we go out often in the summer and the kids and often come home with
ticks is there something i should do um so yeah there is something you should do um you can't you know
different parts of the country you're going to pick up ticks we get ticks i get pull off at least a
dozen or two ticks off of my body every summer where we live so i won't sign a lot you know it's
it just is part of nature um number one is to not be you know fearful of ticks so can ticks um spread
disease yes can certain ticks especially the deer tick have be more prone to sped to spread a tick
related uh uh illness yes um can we test those ticks for an illness for if that tick itself has
line disease yes we can't but there's different labs that can so if you have a tick that's adhered
to you or your loved one if you take that tick off it can be wise to put it on a piece of tape
so that you preserve the tick or the tick will die but you preserve the tick to have it tested
if you have concerns for uh tick-borne illness so some signs of line disease and you or your loved one
would be the feeling of illness typically flu-like stuff um also if you look on our our uh our site
my hope for line i go into details of what a what a uh tick rash looks like a bullseye rash um it's
looks very different than just a rash it's not just red spot it's literally it looks like a bullseye
but it's only a small percentage of people that get that bullseye rash do you get a tick bite on your
head if you pull the tick off your head very slow chance it's you're gonna see any type of bullseye
rash um so how do you know if you have a line disease or not i took this tick off me it was a really
small tick i looked at it uh the internet it's definitely a deer tick how do i know if it has line
or not what should i do well i think you need to watch symptoms now understand just because you got a
bacterial infection doesn't mean that you need to go get a data biotic your body can fight off a
bacteria to benefit your body despite it off bacteria on a daily basis you just don't know what
the reason why you don't know what is because your body is witty your real system is destroying the
bacteria and if you're you're not don't have to worry about it but it's when um that bacterial
infection starts to reproduce to the point where it's making you sick that you might need some aid and if
it is burrelia burrenorphine which is the bacteria involve with line disease i highly recommend you get
it antibiotic because you don't want that that's a very dusty bacteria you don't want it to go crazy
and to move into chronic line disease so having some antibiotics at your whole talking to a live
literate medical doctor that can prescribe antibiotics having somebody in your pocket if you're in an
area where you get a lot of ticks that you should have a relationship with a live literate doctor
so that you can get a prescription that you can have possibly on file so if this happens to you
on the weekend and your child is throwing up flu-like symptoms in the middle of the summer this is
odd nobody else is sick in the house we took a tick off them it looked like a deer tick
um and we know what is going on i think you're i can't prescribe but i would say you're better off
safe than sorry and taking it antibiotic i would if you're going to take an antibiotic i was
to probiotic with it it'll help to finish the negative effects of the antibiotic but you're you're
better off safe than sorry in that case and dealing with any gut issues afterwards those are all
correctable but it's hard to correct it hard to deal with chronic line so you're better off
taking an antibiotic usually it's going to knock it out completely that's one of the ways you'd know
that if it's some viral flu take an antibiotic it doesn't do anything so if it makes the
person's symptoms better many times after just one dose if your doctor used to take it a lot of
antibiotics you're going to have a better response to it and um it can you know i got to say you
should just state a one dose but that's how you know what's a bacterial infection so highly recommend
that so yeah ticks and tick-board illnesses are real they're dangerous and they can ruin a
person's life in a lot of ways they're responsible for creating and stimulating the body to cause
all sorts of inflammatory processes microglial primate autoimmune conditions and they're nasty so
if you could dip it in the bud you're much better off many times in a person you know the difficult
thing is the person may have the symptoms of all a tick-board disease in the summertime when
ticks are present and they never find a tick so what do you do then? Well if you're in if you're
outside and you're exposed to ticks and you some the nips of the deer tick are so small that you
may never find it and you don't get a rash it's difficult because if you're going to go into a doctor
and get a lime test by the time that lab comes back positive or negative you that may have already
moved into the chronic phase so I think a good, literate medical doctor would prescribe based
upon signs and symptoms not solely based upon objective lab tests in the case of a possible lime
I think that's that's an appropriate and wise doctor that you're dealing with they're
looking at okay you were outside you were hiking this all came about nobody else in the family has
this your fever spiked you got you know your feeling ill you got shakes your what's put you on a
bag for a couple days if it knocks it down that we know what's a bacterial or on the right track
if it doesn't then maybe discontinue it and you know eat a lot chicken soup and you know take a bunch
immune stimulants to overcome this and that's the right thing to do so you just got to you don't
always just treat you know based upon one test you treat based upon a differential diagnosis based upon
subjective and objective findings that you gathered from the patients you're making a clinical
assessment based upon that too often we are now living in a world where doctors are simply technicians
that are governed by you know drug companies and they can't make those kind of decisions anymore
unfortunately so you got to find the doctor prior to this all right well thank you for being on our
our list of calories I get to cut it short because of my cold today and I have a patient
coming up quite quickly so please go to holistichealthauer.com you can see all our past shows
and they're well indexed so you can find different topics go to cuttersclinic.com you'll see a thousand
plus blog posts with videos and you can many times get your questions answered there if you want to
make an appointment with me you can self-schedule there too but everything on there is free help yourself
enjoy it look at our courses those are free but nearly free and with that you'll get a ton of
information that you could really take care of many things and that your family or you are struggling
with all right God bless everybody and have a great day we'll see you next week